tschernobyl dieser name steht für angst
seit dem super-gau von mehr als 35
jahren und seit heute wieder wieder
angst wegen tschernobyl denn das
reaktorgelände von tschernobyl im norden
der ukraine ist jetzt von der
stromversorgung abgeschnitten wegen der
kämpfe ganz in der nähe riesige
stromleitung offenbar zerstört russische
truppen haben das gelände ja seit
einigen tagen besetzt die internationale
energiebehörde die den unfall reaktor
eigentlich überwacht die hat derzeit
keinen kontakt mehr dorthin alles
abgerissen wir erinnern uns alle an
diese bilder die
1986 um die welt ging und um es einfach
zu sagen niemand weiß aktuell was auf
diesem nach wie vor hoch gefährlichen
gelände gerade passiert darüber sprechen
wir hier im studium mit meinem reporter
kollegen kai feldhaus du kennst
tschernobyl weil du dort war es auf dem
gelände und die erste frage die mir
heute in den kopf kam die haben keinen
strom mehr dort nach diesen kämpfen rund
um tschernobyl warum braucht der unfall
reaktor das gelände überhaupt noch strom
nun dieser explodierte reaktor der ist
ja nie wirklich aufgeräumt worden man
konnte ja nicht da hingehen und das
abtragen das heißt es hat jahrzehnte
gedauert den in einem strahlend sicheren
sarkophag zu hüllen in dem halt das
material noch jahre und jahrzehnte
weiter vor sich hin strahlen wird und
das muss natürlich gekühlt dieses
material darin muss gekühlt werden weil
du sonst weil sonst gefahr läuft dass
erneut radioaktive dämpfe austreten den
styles wird wie gefährlich ist das jetzt
und was muss da überhaupt noch
kontrolliert werden aktuell
also die die gefahr die von tschernobyl
ausgeht ist natürlich nicht mehr die die
vor 35 jahren waren das ist ja keine
radioaktive keine radioaktive materie
mehr aus sondern das ist ja über jahre
und jahrzehnte kontrolliert worden ich
glaube über 6000 menschen lebten zuletzt
in dieser 30 kilometer durchmesser
todeszone rund um den um den
explodierten reaktor die dafür gesorgt
haben dass dieser reaktor nicht mehr
gefährlich ist wie gefährlich er jetzt
ist das weiß man nicht eben weil es
keinen kontakt dahin gibt und niemand
der das vernünftig einschätzen also an
sich das ist schon gefährlich weil man
aktuell leben ja keinen draht dorthin
hat du warst auf diesem gelände wie kann
ich mir das aktuell vorstellen
tschernobyl sah ich war 2006 dort also
20 jahre nachdem nach der
atomkatastrophe in tschernobyl sieht aus
wie man sich ein szenario in einem
endzeitfilm vorstellt
20 jahre die menschen wurden ja sehr
eilig evakuiert sie haben also quasi
alles stehen und liegen gelassen in
pripjat der größten arbeiterstadt in der
todeszone war schon das volksfest für
den ersten mai aufgebaut dann mussten
alle eigentlich evakuiert werden sehen
wir die klitschkos noch mal dort auch in
tschernobyl and der vater von wladimir
klitschko hat dort ja als feuerwehrmann
ist eben erst dann hat gekämpft und ist
dann später an krebs gestorben dieses
volksfest von dem ich gerade erzählt
habe das war schon aufgebaut und da sind
dann in den 20 jahren danach die gondeln
vom riesenrad runtergefallen ein wald
ist durch den autoscooter gewachsen ist
so die natur holt sich tschernobyl
zurück ist eine auf den ersten blick
sehr friedliche atmosphäre aber das
täuscht natürlich weil das ganze gelände
komplett verseuchtes lebewesen die dort
leben pflanzen dort leben alles komplett
versorgt jetzt hat sich die russische
armee tschernobyl zurückgeholt wenn du
jetzt die aktuellen meldungen höher
tendierten sowieso total verstörenden
verunsichernden ukraine krieg heute eben
die meldung tschernobyl kontakt
abgerissen keine stromversorgung aktuell
mehr man weiß nicht was drin vor sich
geht hast du angst
man weiß ja in diesen tagen und wochen
gar nicht mehr bevor man zuerst angst
haben soll
vor einem überschwappen des krieges
jetzt eine unkontrollierte situation
einem atomkraftwerk das ist natürlich
etwas was
allen sorgen machen sollte was was was
das zu den
ängsten und sorgen die sich aufgebaut
haben noch dazu doch dazu fehlt aber man
kann eigentlich nur hoffen dass beide
konfliktparteien so vernünftig sind dass
zumindest eine waffenruhe eingehalten
wird um den reaktor zu kontrollieren
weil wenn das ding noch mal hoch geht
dann kann es hat auch alle treffen das
weiß ja niemand in welche richtung der
fallout dann marschiert er kann halt
auch genausogut richtung osten nach
russland ziehen und dann ist russland
davon betroffen also da kann man
wirklich nur an alle seiten appelliert
hier jetzt zumindest da einmal vernunft
walten zu lassen und dafür zu sorgen
dass jetzt nicht einfach alle seiten
betroffen sein können vernunft und
bisher auf der prioritätenliste nicht
ganz oben in den vergangenen tagen danke
kai feldhaus unser bild reporter der
selber tschernobyl kennt der das gelände
dort besucht hat das ist eine der
meldungen die sie heute kennen müssen am
tag 14 dieses kriegs atom angst um
tschernobyl kein strom aktuell dort kein
kontakt in diesen unfall reaktor
außerdem putin steht vor der
staatspleite in russland die folge der
westlichen sanktionen vor dem
friedensgipfel so ist er gelabelt morgen
in der türkei spekulationen über eine
neutrale ukraine da geht es auch um die
aufteilung der ukraine dazu gleich mehr
mit unser bild reporter paul ronzheimer
und hier das wissen sie alle ein diesel
beben der größte preissprung bei diesel
den es jemals gegeben hat ein liter
kostet im schnitt zwei euro 15 im
bundesschnitt aktuell und auch das
müssen sie wissen unser bundeskanzler
hat sich gerade geäußert ganz aktuell im
kanzleramt zudem ukraine krieg wenn sich
der angriff russlands auf die ukraine da
sind wir uns einig markiert eine
zeitenwende
für europa aber auch für die
friedensordnung der russische angriff
auf die ukraine ist ein eklatanter
völkerrechts bruch und die welt in der
wir leben ist jetzt nicht mehr dieselbe
wir sehen jetzt viele angriffe auf
ukrainische städte und schulen und
wohnhäuser das leid der bürgerinnen und
bürger der ukraine der menschen im
kriegsgebiet macht uns alle fassungslos
was wir jetzt brauchen ist eine
waffenruhe und mein appell an den
russischen präsidenten ist stoppen sie
das blutvergießen ziehen sie die
russischen truppen zurück es ist eine
schlimme katastrophe für das ukrainische
volk aber auch das russische volk leidet
an diesem krieg ja eine waffenruhe das
ist das entscheidende wort mit blick auf
morgen vor allen dingen diesen
sogenannten friedensgipfel in der türkei
die türkei tritt dort als vermittler auf
da gucken wir mit großer spannung drauf
und schauen aber natürlich auch hier auf
das thema energie in deutschland die
große frage kommen wir ohne putins
cassone putins öl aus das sagt der
kanzler dazu
natürlich stellt sich die frage wie
kriegen wir unsere ehrgeizigen
klimapolitischen ziele umgesetzt noch
einmal zur erinnerung deutschland will
schon bis zum jahr
2045 dass es im knapp 25 jahren
klimaneutral wirtschaften als eines der
erfolgreichsten
industrieländer der welt ist das eine
große herausforderung
es geht um das heizen es geht um
mobilität aber es geht eben auch um die
industriellen prozesse die den größten
teil des energieverbrauchs in unseren
ländern ausmachen und die wir deshalb
auch entsprechend umstellen müssen und
da sind wir uns einig dass es wichtig
ist dass wir diesen weg gehen indem wir
setzen auf den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien auf windkraft offshore und
onshore kanada hat er noch andere
möglichkeiten mit wasserkraft dass wir
die solarenergie fördern unser netz zu
stärken und dass wir eng
zusammenarbeiten bei der nutzung von
wasserstoff
für uns ist wichtig dass wir in dieser
frage eine enge kooperation auf den weg
bringen und genau das haben wir uns
miteinander vorgenommen dass wir alles
dafür tun dass für die wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit unserer länder
wasserstoff den wir gerne auch aus
kanada beziehen wollen eine zentrale
rolle spielt und wir werden dabei auch
die frage der rohstoffe mit dem blick
nehmen denn auch bei uns geht es jetzt
darum zu diversifizieren woher wir die
wichtigen rohstoffe für unsere industrie
bekommen und dabei geht es natürlich
auch um die diversifizierung in den
fragen die für uns wichtig sind wenn es
jetzt um gasimporte geht nach
deutschland da brauchen wir mehr
alternativen gut dass diese auch
gleichzeitig die struktur sein können in
der wir langfristig eine wasserstoff
wirtschaft aufbauen können so ist das in
deutschland geplant ok also um das noch
mal ganz kurz zu übersetzen es bleibt
derzeit bei putins öl und gas es gibt
hier im moment noch keinen klaren
schnitt obwohl natürlich damit auch ganz
wesentlich putins krieg aktuell
finanziert wird nie wieder krieg das
hätte das versprechen an sie seien
müssen an zoe wurde 94 jahre alt sie hat
den holocaust überlebt und erlebt jetzt
wieder krieg nein sagt sie ich gehe die
holocaust das überlebende zoe bordeaux
wird zum kriegsflüchtling
sie will leben einfach nur leben ohne
krieg nicht noch ein
[Musik]
94 jahre alt juden im holocaust hat sie
überlebt
die nachbarn haben mich versteckt ich
habe überlebt habe die besetzung der
stadt erlebt die bomben ich habe nicht
erwartet dass gleiche wieder durchmachen
zu müssen
14 jahre alt war sie damals als der
krieg in ihr leben kam ein mädchen ihre
eltern ermordet jetzt ist der krieg
zurück in ihre heimat bomben auch vor
ihrer haustür in kiew nicht noch einmal
sagte nie wieder krieg sie beschließt zu
gehen
[Musik]
ehrlich gesagt ich will ihn nicht im
kugelhagel sterben oder durch die ganzen
bunten
94 jahre alt jetzt kriegsflüchtling
vitali klitschko ihr bürgermeister hilft
meine ausreise so ist ziel deutschland
ausgerechnet deutschland ihr gepäck
nicht
außer diese beiden silberlöffel von
ihrer mutter
ich habe nur diese löffel mehr ist nicht
geboten alle wertgegenstände alle
erinnerungsstücke sind in den kriegen
und in den jahren danach verloren
gegangen so geht so es reise durch die
ukraine hunderte kilometer über die
ungarische grenze und jetzt nach
deutschland
es ist die unglaubliche geschichte von
seeburger die leben will einfach nur
leben
ja was für eine kriegsgeschichte
mitgebracht von unserem bild reportern
die überall dort in der ukraine und
drumherum für sie im einsatz sind
ich bin von summer und berichte aus der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
aus der miliz
ich bin die mittelsäule und ich berichte
aus der slowakei
dieter thiede aus russland
bei nebel aus new york und
sie alle werden wir gleich sehen wir
starten bei paul ronzheimer der heute
das sehen sie auf diesen etwas
wackeligen bildern aus kiew unterwegs
war mit den klitschkos in einem kieler
krankenhaus in einem kriegs krankenhaus
wir sind jetzt verbunden mit paul
ronzheimer und wollen genau darüber
sprechen über seine eindrücke mit
wladimir wird vitali unterwegs in diesem
krankenhaus paul was hast du dort
gesehen an angst an not an leid
sehr großes leica aber nimmst mir nicht
übel wenn ich ganz kurz bezug nehme auch
sei die dort gerade raus gekommen ist
weil ich das persönlich auch tief bewegt
um zu erklären wie das vielleicht
entstanden ist so ihre tochter hat sich
in den sozialen medien zu wort gemeldet
und hat gefragt wer kann helfen wer kann
etwas tun so hat mich dann dort jemand
kontaktiert und ich wiederum habe dann
mit vitali klitschko gesprochen der das
innerhalb von tagen umgesetzt hat diese
evakuierung einer holocaust-überlebenden
und ihm war das besonders wichtig
natürlich dieser 94 jährigen frau zu
helfen die so viel durchgemacht hat in
ihrem leben und er sagt das ist eben
auch ein symbol dafür was hier so vielen
menschen passiert was in der ukraine
passiert und was für einen grausamen
krieg vladimir putin führt dass eine
holocaust-überlebende angst haben muss
vor seinen okay
wir sehen gerade noch mal die bilder
paul dann fangen wir euch damit an du
hast sie ja selbst auch getroffen du
hast sie erlebt dort in kiew peter hell
unser bild reporter hat sie erlebt und
ein stück weit begleitet was ist das für
eine frau
für die 94 jahre eine
wahnsinnige frau immer noch ich weiß von
ihrem sohn dass sie auf kiews nicht
verlassen wollte die tochter die in den
usa lebt und mit der ich eben diesen
kontakt hatte ihr tweet hatte sich
hunderttausend mal wurde der mit treated
und jemand hat mich sozusagen getagt so
nennt man das in der twitter sprache ob
ich helfen könne ich habe dann kontakt
aufgenommen mit der tochter die in san
francisco oder bei san francisco vor und
als ich dann bei ihr zuhause war
ungefähr 15 autominuten von hier
entfernt da habe ich eine wahnsinnig
fitte wahnsinnig kluge und eine frau
gesehen die nicht raus wollte dort aus
ihrer wohnung sie musste überredet
werden aber sie hat gesagt ich will noch
ein bisschen leben ich will noch leben
und ich habe davor angst dass die
raketen hier in mein haus fliegen in
kiew und ich nicht mehr leben werde und
habe mir die ich gerade gesehen
unterwegs heute durch kiew durch eines
der großen krankenhäuser dort in der
stadt wir können die bilder gerade
nochmal sehen du bist mit den beiden
klitschkos dort unterwegs gewesen dort
wo diejenigen eintreffen die schwere
verletzungen schwere verwundungen haben
von diesem krieg was hast du dort erlebt
in diesem krankenhaus
bleibe ich mit vitali klitschko reisen
sozusagen oder fahren sehr viel durch
die stadt um sich an checkpoints zu
erkundigen in krankenhäusern heute dort
sind über 500 verletzte ukrainische
soldaten und tatsächlich ist es eine
dramatische situation dieser front
beschreiben das krankenhaus und auch die
armee für so ein bisschen verhindern
dass man
verletzte soldaten zeigt dass es in
vielen kriegen so man will sozusagen die
armee nicht verwunden zeigen das ist
etwas was viele annehmen machen aber es
ist natürlich die realität und in diesem
krankenhaus jetzt neben den verletzten
soldaten war noch viele
krankenschwestern ärzte pfleger die dann
für einen moment sozusagen diesen krieg
vergessen konnten mal für fünf minuten
als sie dann 111 ii mit vitali und werde
mit klitschko macht durften du hast paul
gestern mit vitali gesprochen und da ist
mir ein einsatz aus diesem interview
nicht aus dem kopf gegangen du hattest
ihn gefragt was wird passieren wenn die
russischen truppen dann eben doch kommen
wenn die doch in kiew steht und dann
sagt vitali klitschko die kommen niemals
niemals woher nimmt er diese zuversicht
und was glaubst du was die klitschkos
sagen wie man eben putin wie man seine
armee stoppen kann dass das genau nicht
passieren
die selbst sagen ganz klar die haben wir
es nur durch internationalen druck zu
stoppen durch waffen durch ein
engagement des westens und der hilfe des
westens sie alleine werden das nicht
können aber er nimmt diesen will diesen
mut weil er sagt die ukraine stehen
zusammen und werden hier wenn es denn so
kommen sollte tatsächlich häuserkampf
führen und gegen die russische armee
kennen
jetzt schauen wir paul auf das was
morgen passiert friedensgipfel heißt das
in der türkei findet das ganze stadt in
antalya unter deren vermittlung
sozusagen dort treffen sich die
aussenminister welcher hoffnung hast du
mit blick darauf und wird dort gerade
ganz platt gesagt die ukraine
möglicherweise verhökert
hoffnung ist da die frage ist was will
die ukraine was kann die ukraine geben
wenn sie lenski nachgibt dann ist die
große frage was sagt die bevölkerung
dazu nachgeben würde bedeuten
neutralität keine nato wahrscheinlich
ein akzeptierung der krim und
möglicherweise der gebiete lokals grund
dort als unabhängig das wäre schon sehr
sehr schwer für die bevölkerung zu
akzeptieren und ich glaube das ist die
entscheidende frage werden sie lenski
darauf eingehen sollte machen die bürger
und bürgerinnen das mit danke paul
ronzheimer in die kriegs hauptstadt nach
kiew danke für den moment